determine the number of solutions to the
quadratic equation x squared plus 14x
plus 49 is equal to zero there's a bunch
of ways we could do it we could factor
it and just figure out the values of X
that satisfied and just count them
that'll be the number of solutions we
could just apply the quadratic formula
but what I want to do here is actually
explore the quadratic formula and think
about how we can determine the number of
solutions without even maybe necessarily
finding them explicitly so the quadratic
formula tells us that if we have an
equation of the form ax squared plus BX
plus C is equal to 0 that the solutions
are going to be or the solution if it
exists is going to be negative B plus or
minus the square root of b squared minus
4ac all of that over 2a now the reason
why this is two solutions or the reason
why this can be two solutions is that we
have a plus or minus here if this b
squared minus 4ac is a positive number
so let's think about this a little bit
if b squared minus 4ac is greater than
zero what's going to happen well then
it's it's a positive number it's going
to have a square root and then when you
add it to negative B over 2a or when you
add it to negative B you're going to get
one value for the numerator and when you
subtract it from negative B you're going
to get another value in the numerator so
this is going to lead to two solutions
two solutions now what happens if if b
squared minus 4ac is equal to zero if
this expression under the radical is
equal to zero or just going to have the
square root of zero so it's going to be
negative B plus or minus zero and
doesn't matter what you add or subtract
zero you're going to get the same value
so in that situation the actual solution
of the equation is going to be negative
B over 2a there's not going to be this
plus or minus it's not going to be
relevant so you're only going to have
one solution
so if b squared minus 4ac is equal to
zero you only have one solution and then
what happens if b squared minus 4ac is
less than zero
well if b squared minus 4ac is less than
zero this is going to be a negative
number right here and you're going to
take the square root of a negative
number and we know if we're dealing with
real numbers you can't take the square
root there is no real number squared
that becomes a negative number so in
this situation there is no solutions or
no real when I say real I literally mean
like a real number no real solution no
real solution so let's think about it in
the context of this equation right here
and just in case you're curious if
whether this this this expression right
here b squared minus 4ac has a name it
does it's called the discriminant this
criminal discriminant this is the
discriminant that's that part of the
quadratic equation it determines the
number of solutions we have so if we
want to figure out the number of
solutions this equation we we don't have
to go through the whole quadratic
equation although it's not that much
work we just have to evaluate b squared
minus 4ac so what is b squared minus 4ac
so b is right here it's 14 so it's 14
squared minus 4 times a which is 1 times
C which is 49 that's C right there times
49
well what's 14 times 14 14 you do it
over here
14 times B 14 times 14 4 times 4 is 16 4
times 1 is 4 plus 1 is 56 put a 0 1
times 14 is 14 it is 6 9 1 it's 196 so
this right here is 196 and that's what's
we could ignore the 1 what's 4 times 49
so 49 times 4 4 times 9 is 6
sorry it's 36 not 46 it's 36 4 times 4
is 16 plus 3 is 190 or is 19 so you get
196 so this right here is 196 so B
squared minus 4 AC is 196 minus 196 so
196 minus 196 is equal to 0 so we're
dealing with a situation where the
discriminant is equal to 0 we only have
one solution and if you want you could
try to find that one solution this whole
part is just going to be the square root
of zero it's just going to be zero so
the solution is going to be negative B
over 2a and negative B is we could just
solve it negative B is negative 14 over
2 times a a is just 1 over 2 so it's
equal to negative 7 that's the only
solution this equation but if you just
wanted to know how many solutions you
just have to find out that B squared
minus 4ac is 0 so it's only going to
have one solution and there's other ways
you could have actually factored this
pretty easily into X plus 7 times X plus
7 and gotten the same result